Ask most people about the things that are important to them, about what really matters in their life and what makes them happy. And you'll hear a common refrain, my spouse or partner, my children, my family, my closest friends. Close relationships are essential to our happiness and well-being, and decades of research have shown that they're also important predictors of physical health. Why is that? What kind of support do we receive from our partners and other close relationships,
问大多数人什么对他们最重要，生命中最在乎什么，以及什么能让他们快乐，你都会听到一个共同的答案：我的配偶或伴侣、我的孩子、我的家人、我最亲密的朋友。亲密关系对我们的幸福感和健康至关重要，几十年的研究表明，它们也是身体健康的重要预测指标。这是为什么呢？我们从伴侣和其他亲密关系中获得了什么样的支持，
and why does that support matter so much? What are the biological mechanisms that tie together social relationships and health? What are the ingredients of a good and supportive relationship and how do we develop these deep ties to each other? Also, how has the COVID-19 pandemic affected our close relationships? Are people coming out of the past year and a half feeling a stronger connection to their loved ones or have those ties frayed? And what, if any, lasting effects might we see?
这种支持为什么如此重要？将社会关系和健康联系在一起的生物学机制是什么？一段良好且相互支持的关系的要素是什么，我们又是如何培养彼此之间这种深厚联系的？此外，COVID-19疫情对我们的亲密关系产生了怎样的影响？在经历过去的一年半之后，人们与挚爱的联系是变得更强了，还是这些纽带已经磨损？如果说有什么持久的影响的话，我们可能会看到什么？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Richard Slatcher, a professor of psychology and head of the Close Relationships Laboratory at the University of Georgia. He studies how our intimate relationships get under our skin to affect our health and well-being, how people come to feel close to each other, and how technology, like smartphones and social media may be affecting our closest relationships. For the past year, he's also been running a study called Love in the Time of COVID that's looked at how people's relationships have been faring through
欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是佐治亚大学（University of Georgia）心理学教授兼亲密关系实验室（Close Relationships Laboratory）负责人理查德·斯莱彻（Richard Slatcher）博士。他研究我们的亲密关系是如何深入我们的骨髓并影响我们的健康和幸福感的，人们是如何对彼此产生亲密感的，以及智能手机和社交媒体等技术可能如何影响我们最亲密的关系。在过去的一年里，他还一直在主持一项名为“疫情之爱”（Love in the Time of COVID）的研究，该研究着眼于人们的关系在
the pandemic. We'll try to discuss all of that today. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Slatcher. That's great to be here, Kim. It might seem kind of obvious that good relationships make us happier. But as I just mentioned a few moments ago, there are many years of research now suggesting that they make us healthier too. So let's start with a broad question. How and why are relationships important to our health and well-being? What's the scientific evidence? I guess let's start with the well-being question. When you open this segment, it reminded me of one of my intellectual heroes who passed away this year, Ed Deiner, at the University of Illinois, who was really the father of happiness research. And it was his research that really
疫情期间的发展情况。我们今天将尝试讨论所有这些。欢迎您的到来，斯莱彻博士。很高兴来到这里，金。好的关系能让我们更快乐，这似乎是一件显而易见的事。但正如我刚才提到的那样，多年的研究现在表明，它们也能让我们更健康。因此，让我们从一个宽泛的问题开始。关系对我们的健康和幸福感为何以及如何重要？科学证据是什么？我想我们先从幸福感的问题开始吧。当你开启这个话题时，让我想起了今年去世的一位我的学术偶像，伊利诺伊大学的埃德·迪纳（Ed Deiner），他 realmente 是幸福研究之父。正是他的研究
pointed us to how important social relationships are for our well-being. And he showed that all of the people who indicate on a one to ten scale that they're at the most happy 10, all of them to a person indicate having a close friend in their lives. And it's research that like that that's really kept me going because time and time again we see how important our relationships are for how happy we are and increasingly we're finding out for how healthy we are too. I once gave a talk about five years or so was an interdisciplinary conference, a small meeting. And the person before me was an exercise physiologist. And at the beginning of their talk, they said, I challenge anyone to argue with me about the importance of physical activity. You can't overstate the importance of physical activity.
向我们指明了社会关系对我们的幸福感有多么重要。他发现，所有在一到十分的量表上标示自己处于最快乐的“10分”的人，无一例外地都表明他们的生活中有一个密友。正是这样的研究一直激励着我，因为我们一次又一次地看到，我们的关系对我们的快乐程度有多么重要，而且我们越来越发现，它对我们的健康状况也同样重要。大约五年前，我在一个跨学科会议（一个小会议）上作了一次演讲。排在我前面的那个人是一位运动生理学家。在演讲开始时，他们说：“我向任何人发起挑战，来跟我争论体力活动的重要性。你无论如何强调体力活动的重要性都不为过。”
And I came up and I talked next. And I said, I don't mean to try to top you, but. And then I showed her a graph of basically all of the different things that are associated with longevity, including not. smoking, including physical activity, including not being a, you know, fairly low weight and things like that. And right at the top was our social relationships. And it's a pretty robust finding that people who are more socially connected live longer. And there are all kinds of fascinating studies. There's a great study that you might have heard of called the nuns study, where they studied these nuns over several decades.
然后我上台进行了接下来的演讲。我说：“我并不是想压倒你，但是……”接着我向她展示了一张图表，图表列出了基本上所有与长寿相关的不同因素，包括不吸烟、包括体力活动、包括体重不太重等等。而排在最顶端的正是我们的社会关系。这是一个相当稳健的发现，即社会联系更多的人寿命更长。这里有各种各样引人入胜的研究。有一个你可能听说过的伟大的研究，叫做修女研究（Nuns Study），他们对这些修女进行了几十年的研究。
And nuns are a great group to study because they all live in the same environment, physical environment. So you're controlling for a lot of extremist factors. And by a mile, the nuns who had the closest relationships lived the longest, and the nuns who are the happiest live the longest. And we've seen this in the Harvard Men's study, you know, that's been going on for close to 100 years now. And so it's really these kind of, you know, the early work in this area that to me was so compelling that got me to shift from just studying the basics of what makes relationships tick and what makes relationships succeed and fail to really how they're, they are tied to why we are happy and healthy.
修女是一个很好的研究群体，因为她们都生活在相同的环境中，即物理环境。因此你控制了很多混杂因素。毫无疑问，关系最亲密的修女活得最久，最快乐的修女也活得最久。我们在哈佛大学男性研究（Harvard Men's Study）中也看到了这一点，你知道，这项研究已经持续了近100年。因此，确实是这一类早期研究（在我看来是如此引人注目）促使我从仅仅研究关系运转的基本原理、关系成败的原因，转向真正研究它们是如何与我们为何快乐健康联系在一起的。
Much of your research has focused specifically on marriages and other long-term intimate relationships. Are these benefits true for other close relationships too? I mean, you just talked about nuns, so they must be right. I mean, because nuns aren't married, and married to Jesus, they're married to God. But what about other close friendships and family relationships? Are the benefits that people derive equivalent to the benefits that they might get from a long-term intimate partner? Absolutely. I mean, when I think about the size of the effects that we see for intimate relationships,
你的许多研究都特别集中在婚姻和其他长期亲密关系上。这些益处对其他亲密关系也同样适用吗？我的意思是，你刚才谈到了修女，所以它们一定适用，对吧？我的意思是，因为修女没有结婚，与耶稣结婚，她们是嫁给了上帝。但其他亲密友谊和家庭关系呢？人们从这些关系中获得的益处，是否等同于他们从长期亲密伴侣那里获得的益处？绝对是的。我的意思是，当我想到我们看到的亲密关系的效应大小时，
and we did what's called a meta-analysis or an analysis of many papers, all the papers that have been done at the time, this is about five years ago, on the links between marital satisfaction and longevity. And when you look at other studies that have looked at just social connectedness in terms of how integrated you are with your social network, the social network findings are actually bigger. So although your marriage, if you are married, really impacts your physical health, those other close relationships that we have are enormously important to. And I say close relationships because those are the ones that we've studied like marriage, friendships to a lesser extent, parent-child relationships to a greater extent. Not really, one of the things I've become interested
我们做了一个所谓的元分析（Meta-analysis），即对当时许多论文（关于婚姻满意度与长寿之间联系的所有已发表论文）进行的分析，这大约是五年前的事。当你观察其他研究时，那些仅仅从社会网络整合度（即你与社会网络的融合程度）角度来考察社会联系的研究，其社会网络的研究结果实际上更大。因此，尽管你的婚姻（如果你已婚的话）确实会极大地影响你的身体健康，但我们拥有的其他亲密关系也同样极其重要。我之所以说“亲密关系”，是因为这些是我们研究过的关系，比如婚姻、在较小程度上的友谊、在更大程度上的亲子关系。其实，我在疫情期间变得感兴趣的一件事
in actually during the pandemic is the importance of not. non-close relationships, you know, that's something that we've, a lot of us have lost. But yes, absolutely. Friendships, for example, just matter so much. Ed Deiner showed us that. We've done some podcasts where we've talked to people about the importance of even sort of ships in the night kinds of relationships where you may just have a conversation with a stranger and how you derive benefits from that. So let me ask you, then, what are the biological mechanisms that underlie the link between
实际上是非亲密关系的重要性，你知道，那是我们很多人都失去的东西。但是的，绝对的。比如友谊，就非常重要。埃德·迪纳向我们展示了这一点。我们做过一些播客，跟人们讨论过哪怕是那种“萍水相逢”式的关系的重要性，即你可能只是和陌生人进行了一次对话，以及你是如何从中获得益处的。那么，请允许我问你，那么，联系背后的生物学机制是什么？
relationships and health? You talk about relationships get under our skin. What do you mean by that? So that's a tougher question to answer, in part because the science is changing so quickly on what we call biomarkers in health psychology, those specific physiological markers that we can assess that seem to, on the one hand, robustly predict physical health outcomes like asthma morbidity, for example, cardiovascular functioning, risk of heart attack, and that are also associated with relationships.
关系与健康之间的关系？你谈到“关系深入我们的骨髓”，你这是什么意思？这是一个更难回答的问题，部分原因是健康心理学中所谓的生物标志物（biomarkers）科学发展得太快了，那些我们可以评估的特定生理标记，它们一方面似乎能够强有力地预测身体健康结果，例如哮喘发病率、心血管功能、心脏病发作风险，另一方面也与关系有关。
And if you look at the history of health psychology, you can see if you take a snapshot of, say, 40 years ago, the hot thing was like heart rate and blood pressure. And then it starts moving toward different markers of the immune system 20 or 30 years ago, some of Sheldon Cohen's work, the researcher who studied the links between stress and the common cold, where he starts looking at. at what we call pro-inflammatory cytokines, which are markers of inflammation in the immune system. We start seeing studies of cortisol. So we're looking at, we've looked at all of these things.
如果你回顾健康心理学的发展史，你会发现如果你截取比如40年前的一个时间断面，最热门的话题是心率和血压。然后，在20或30年前，它开始转向免疫系统的不同标志物，比如谢尔顿·科恩（Sheldon Cohen）的一些研究（这位研究压力与普通感冒之间联系的研究人员），他开始关注我们所说的促炎细胞因子（pro-inflammatory cytokines），它们是免疫系统中炎症的标志物。我们开始看到关于皮质醇（cortisol）的研究。所以我们一直在观察所有这些事情。
And I would say the most compelling evidence for relationships linking health are mortality findings. And you see that time and time again. Mortality is pretty easy to measure. Whereas when you're measuring something like pro-inflammatory cytokines from a one-shot blood draw, Our cytokine levels fluctuate greatly across the day. And so it's a much less precise measure. Having said that, we have found more positive social relationships in kids. We've looked at we have a big study that's been going on for about 10 years in Detroit,
我想说，关系与健康相联系的最令人信服的证据是死亡率的研究。你一次又一次地看到这一点。死亡率相对容易测量。然而，当你通过单次抽血来测量像促炎细胞因子这样的指标时，我们的细胞因子水平在一天当中会剧烈波动。因此，这是一个精确度低得多的测量指标。话虽如此，我们在儿童身上发现了更多积极的社会关系。我们观察过——我们在底特律进行了一项历时约10年的大型研究，
Michigan of youth with asthma. And we've shown that positive parent-child relationships are associated with lower levels of inflammation in these youth and that those levels of inflammation aren't in turn associated with better asthma symptoms. We've looked a lot at the stress hormone cortisol, which is naturally secreted throughout the day, does a lot of things, primarily metabolic function, but is a good measure of stress. We have some pretty consistent evidence that positive social relationships are associated with a steeper decline in cortisol across the day. We'll have people, we've done a few studies like this where you give people a little cotton swabs to take home with them. And over a long
密歇根州患有哮喘的青少年。我们已经证明，积极的亲子关系与这些青少年较低的炎症水平相关，而这些炎症水平反过来又与更好的哮喘症状相关。我们对压力激素皮质醇进行了大量研究，它在全天自然分泌，具有多种功能，主要是代谢功能，但它也是衡量压力的一个很好的指标。我们有一些相当一致的证据表明，积极的社会关系与全天皮质醇水平更陡峭的下降有关。我们会让人们——我们做过一些这样的研究，你给人们一些小棉签让他们带回家。在漫长的
weekend, from say a Friday through a Monday, six times a day, they'll chew on a little cotton swab at predetermined times to capture the circadian rhythm of cortisol. And then on those individual days, we'll either ask them about what their relationships are like, or we also use this device that's that's an app on Android and an iPhone called the electronically activated recorder or the ear to sort of take a fly on the wall perspective of people's social interactions which is a great objective way of tapping into relationships and either way you look at it if it's self-reports daily reports or through the ear through sound files that are coded by our research assistance you find these same kinds of effects with sort of quote
周末里，比如从星期五到星期一，一天六次，他们在预定的时间咀嚼一根小棉签，以捕捉皮质醇的昼夜节律。然后在那些日子里，我们要么询问他们关于他们的关系是什么样的，要么我们还使用一种设备，它是安卓和iPhone上的一个应用程序，叫做电子激活记录仪（electronically activated recorder，简称EAR），从“墙上苍蝇”的角度来观察人们的社会社交互动，这是深入了解关系的一个极好的客观方法。无论你如何看待它，如果是自我报告、每日报告，或是通过电子激活记录仪捕捉由我们的研究助手编码的声音文件，你都会发现这些相同类型的效应，即所谓更健康的皮质醇模式与更健康的婚姻功能相关。
healthier cortisol patterns being associated with healthier relationship functioning. But are those things going to be the holy grail of our understanding of why relationships are associated with health? I doubt it. But they all point in the same direction. Showing that relationships are associated with health-related physiology. And I think one of the most exciting things about this line of research that keeps me interested, is that we're learning more and more every year about how this works from a biological standpoint. So not all marriages are good ones, of course, and bad marriages can also have an effect on our health. What are the differences between those kinds of relationships that lead to better health and well-being and those that don't?
但是，这些东西会成为我们理解为什么关系与健康有关的“圣杯”吗？我对此表示怀疑。但它们都指向同一个方向，表明关系与健康相关的生理学有关。我认为这项研究最令人兴奋的事情之一、也是让我保持兴趣的事情，是我们每年都在从生物学的角度更多地了解这是如何运作的。当然，并非所有的婚姻都是美好的，糟糕的婚姻也会对我们的健康产生影响。那些能够带来更好健康和幸福感的关系与不能的关系，它们之间有什么区别？
So that's a good question because, you know, there's this general finding that being married is good for your health. And that is on the whole true. But if you dig deeper, it's much better to not be married for your health and well-being than it is to be in a bad marriage. And so you're asking what constitutes sort of, you know, the negative sorts of aspects of marriage that we're looking at that are associated with poor health. The biggest thing is conflict and how people have conflict. Much of our work is in line with some of the classic studies in clinical and social psychology
这是一个很好的问题，因为，你知道，有一个普遍的发现，即结婚对你的健康有益。总的来说，这确实是真的。但如果你深入挖掘，为了你的健康和幸福感，不结婚其实比身处一段糟糕的婚姻要好得多。所以你问的是，我们所关注的、与健康状况不佳相关的婚姻中消极方面的成分究竟是什么？最大的因素是冲突以及人们如何产生冲突。我们的许多工作都符合临床和社会心理学的一些经典研究，
that John Gottman and others did in the lab where they found that levels of hostility in conflict discussions and low levels of positive emotions in trying to resolve conflict are associated with poor health, a former graduate student of mine who's now a professor, Sabrina Byerstedel, just published a paper last year looking at this where we had couples interacting in the lab trying to resolve a long-standing disagreement. Of course, they never resolve it. But the point is to try to see how they try to resolve it. And so we found exactly what she had predicted,
比如约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）和其他人在实验室里所做的研究，他们发现冲突讨论中的敌对程度高、以及在试图解决冲突时积极情绪水平低，都与健康状况不佳有关。我的一位前研究生、现在是一名教授的萨布丽娜·拜尔斯泰德尔（Sabrina Byerstedel），去年刚刚发表了一篇论文，探讨了这个问题。我们在实验室里让伴侣们互动，试图解决一个长期的分歧。当然，他们从未真正解决它。但重点是看他们是如何试图解决它的。因此我们发现了完全符合她预测的结果，
which was that these hostile behaviors that come out in these interactions among some couples were associated after they left the lab with dysregulated cortisol patterns in daily life, with a less, steep decline in cortisol throughout the day. In other words, the cortisol stayed high for those couples. So I would say conflict is the big one, but also a lack of positive emotions, too. You know, those intimate relationships that are lacking humor, that are lacking, caring, and that are lacking one big thing that I've looked at throughout my almost 20 years doing this
即在某些伴侣的这些互动中表现出的这些敌对行为，在他们离开实验室后，与日常生活中的皮质醇失调模式有关，表现为全天皮质醇下降幅度较小。换句话说，对于这些伴侣来说，皮质醇保持在高位。所以我想说，冲突是最大的一个因素，但缺乏积极情绪也是。你知道，那些缺乏幽默感、缺乏关怀、并且缺乏我在近20年的关系研究中一直关注的一个重大因素的亲密关系，
research and relationships. And that is what we call perceived partner responsiveness. This is a really, really important thing for relationships, not just for your own physical health and well-being, but especially for the health of the relationship. And so the idea here is that partners vary in the extent to which they make each other feel understood, really listened to, cared for, validated. You know, it's not just being a good listener, but that's a big part of it. It's also being responsive to your partner's needs, being sensitive, you know, knowing when they might need what we call instrumental support or, you know,
那就是我们所说的感知到的伴侣响应性（perceived partner responsiveness）。这对关系来说是一件非常非常重要的事情，不仅对你自己的身体健康和幸福感很重要，对关系的健康尤其重要。所以这里的观点是，伴侣在多大程度上让他们彼此感到被理解、被真正倾听、被关怀、被认可，这是因人而异的。你知道，这不仅仅是做一个好的倾听者，尽管这是其中很大一部分。它还包括对伴侣的需求做出响应，保持敏感，你知道，知道他们什么时候可能需要我们所说的工具性支持（instrumental support），或者，
taking out the garbage, helping clean the kitchen, help take the kids somewhere, being sensitive to those kinds of things. Those positive aspects of responsiveness we found are really important in terms of predicting health. A former postdoc of mine, Sarah Stanton, had a really nice paper published a couple of years ago in the journal Psychosomatic Medicine where she showed over a 20-year period from a large data set called Midlife in the United States that's at the University of Wisconsin publicly available data of a few thousand people that perceived partner responsiveness at the very beginning of the study predicted 10 years later how people were responding.
倒垃圾，帮忙清理厨房，帮忙带孩子去某处，对这类事情保持敏感。我们发现，这些响应性的积极方面在预测健康方面非常重要。我的前博士后萨拉·斯坦顿（Sarah Stanton）几年前在《身心医学》（Psychosomatic Medicine）杂志上发表了一篇非常优秀的论文，她在其中展示了来自威斯康星大学（University of Wisconsin）一个名为“美国中年”（Midlife in the United States）的大型数据集长达20年的跟踪研究。这是一个公开的数据集，包含数千人。研究表明，在研究开始时感知到的伴侣响应性，可以预测10年之后人们是如何反应的。
to daily stressors and those people who earlier, 10 years earlier, said that they had partners who were really responsive to them, well, they were less emotionally reactive to stressors 10 years later. So they would have the same stressors, but they were reacting less to them. And that in turn, 10 years after that or 20 years from the beginning of the study, predicted lower levels of mortality. So this is, you know, one of the things that I'm really interested in is not just understanding from a biological standpoint, how relationships get under the skin, but from a psychological one.
对于日常生活中的压力源，那些在10年前表示拥有真正有响应性的伴侣的人，嗯，他们在10年后对压力源的情绪反应较小。因此，他们会遇到同样的压力源，但他们的反应较小。这反过来又在研究开始后的20年（即前一个10年之后的10年）预测了较低的死亡率。所以，你知道，我真正感兴趣的事情之一，不仅是从生物学的角度理解关系是如何深入骨髓的，还要从心理学的角度去理解。
So what are the, what we call mechanisms here? And so emotionality seems to be a key part of it. We've seen that in a few different studies of ours. But I think this is, what's so nice about this is that you have multiple time points and you can really help to better ascertain the causal direction of these things. So it's interesting to me that so far sex hasn't come up. And I'm wondering the importance of that in relationships as well. I mean, it doesn't matter whether it's there, how good it is, or whether it's just about communications generally and the ability to resolve conflict. That's a really important question, Kim.
那么，我们所说的机制是什么？情绪性似乎是其中的一个关键部分。我们在我们的一些不同研究中也看到了这一点。但我认为，这之所以这么好，是因为你有多个时间点，你可以真正帮助更好地确定这些事情的因果方向。所以对我来说有趣的是，到目前为止还没有谈到性。我也想知道性在关系中的重要性。我的意思是，性是否存在、质量如何，或者它是否仅仅关乎普遍的沟通以及解决冲突的能力？这是一个非常重要的问题，金。
What I can tell you is that over the last 10 years, sex research, at least within social psychology and the study of relationships, has been at the vanguard. I think a lot of the most excited. research has been in the areas of sexual satisfaction and what leads to a sexually healthy relationship. And we've seen an explosion in this kind of research that when I, the big annual meeting of social psychologists, we have a separate submeeting at the beginning of the conference for those people that study close relationships. And there are now so many people that study
我可以告诉你的是，在过去10年里，性研究（至少在社会心理学和关系研究领域）一直处于最前沿。我认为许多最激动人心的研究都集中在性满意度和什么能带来性健康关系的领域。我们已经看到这类研究呈爆炸式增长。当我参加社会心理学家的大型年会时，我们在会议开始时为那些研究亲密关系的人设置了一个单独的分会。现在有太多研究性与关系的人了，以至于他们有了自己的会前会。
sex and relationships that they have their own pre-conference. Having said that, there's been not that much work that I'm aware of and some of my colleagues who are more expert in that area of research might correct me about this, but I don't know of much research that has looked at sexual satisfaction and say predicting mortality, for example, or some sorts of biomarkers of health. But I think it's really important that we start looking at it because just so many studies have shown that sexual satisfaction is really important to relationships. You can be happy in a relationship where you're not terribly satisfied with your sex life, but if you are really satisfied with your sex life, you're much more likely to be happy
话虽如此，据我所知，并没有做过太多相关工作——那些在该研究领域更具权威的同行可能会纠正我——但我不知道有什么研究探讨过性满意度能否预测死亡率，或者能否预测某些健康的生物标志物。但我认为我们开始研究它是非常重要的，因为太多的研究表明，性满意度对关系真的很重要。你可能在一桩对性生活不是十分满意的关系中感到快乐，但如果你对性生活真的很满意，你在那段关系中感到快乐的可能性就会大得多。
in that relationship. That makes sense on its face. Well, let's switch for a minute and talk about technology. You published a study a couple of years ago called Smartphones in Close Relationships, the case for an evolutionary mismatch. How are smartphones interfering with people's relationships these days? Are we spending more time on our phones now than we are talking to our spouses? Or is that just a New Yorker cartoon?
表面上看这确实说得通。好吧，让我们换个话题，谈谈技术。你几年前发表了一项名为《亲密关系中的智能手机：演化错配的例证》（Smartphones in Close Relationships, the case for an evolutionary mismatch）的研究。如今智能手机是如何干扰人们的关系的？我们现在花在手机上的时间是否比跟配偶交谈的时间还要多？还是这仅仅是《纽约客》（New Yorker）的一幅漫画？
This has been one of the lines of research that I've been most interested in the last couple of years is how all of this new technology. And it's still very new from an evolutionary standpoint, of course. But even in recent memory, it's still all pretty new, how all of that impacts our relationships. And so from a theoretical standpoint, social media shouldn't be all that great for helping us to build close relationships. We can build somewhat superficial relationships online and they can become deeper if they become offline relationships. But the idea that online interactions on social media are going to really foster a deep sense
这是我过去几年最感兴趣的研究方向之一，即所有这些新技术——从演化的角度来看，它当然仍然非常新。但即使在最近的记忆中，它仍然相当新——所有这一切是如何影响我们的关系的。因此从理论的角度来看，社交媒体在帮助我们建立亲密关系方面并不是那么好。我们可以在网上建立某种程度上肤浅的关系，如果它们变成线下关系，它们可以变得更深厚。但那种认为社交媒体上的互动会真正培养出一种深厚连接感的观点，
of connection is very much at odds with evolutionary history and why we devise. developed to be very social creatures. We developed to be social creatures in small groups, primarily diads or groups of two or three or four people. And it's in those groups kind of only that you can really feel a sense of intimacy. It's hard if I'm sending out a tweet to hundreds, thousands, or even millions of people, I'm not going to necessarily feel close to those people who are reacting to my tweet, even if it's overwhelmingly positive. It might make me feel good, but I'm not going to feel deeply connected. And so that's really the evolutionary mismatch there that we have these tools that are supposed to make us feel connected, but at least from what we
与演化历史以及我们为什么被设计成非常具有社会性的生物是极不相符的。我们被演化成在小群体中具有社会性的生物，主要是双人组（diads）或两三个人的群体。只有在这些群体中，你才能真正感受到一种亲密感。如果我向成百上千甚至数百万的人发送推文，这就很难做到，我不一定会对那些对我的推文作出反应的人感到亲密，即使反应绝大多数是积极的。它可能会让我感觉良好，但我不会感到深刻的连接。所以这确实是其中的演化错配，我们拥有这些本应让我们感到连接的工具，但至少从我们对关系如何运作的了解来看，它们不一定能做到这一点。
know about how relationships work, they shouldn't necessarily. Now, are they bad for us? Most of the good research out there suggests that social media use has very little impact on our well-being in terms of good or bad. It's sort of a net neutral. There have been some really good, rigorous meta-analysis done the last couple of years where people are using better measures, more objective measures of screen time use and time spent on social media. And when you take a step back away from self-reports, I should say self-reports, you know, if I ask you, how much do you use social media and how happy you are, there's a, you know, generally a small correlation between self-reported, how much I say I'm using social media and lower well-being.
那么，它们对我们有害吗？现有的绝大多数优秀研究表明，社交媒体的使用对我们关于好坏的幸福感影响微乎其微。它基本上是一个净中立因素。在过去几年里，进行了一些非常优秀、严谨的元分析，人们使用了更好的测量方法、更客观的屏幕使用时间和社交媒体花费时间的测量方法。当你退一步，远离自我报告时，我应该说，自我报告——你知道，如果我问你，你使用多少社交媒体，你有多快乐，自我报告的说自己使用多少社交媒体与较低的幸福感之间通常存在一个很小的相关性。
But when you take a step away from self-reports, people are so, they have no clue how much time they actually spend on social media. So when you actually look objectively, what we found is there's very little, if any, association, which surprised me, for example, between how much couples are using their smartphones and how satisfied they are in their relationship. It really seems to be when it comes to the effect of our phones on our intimate relationships, at least. It seems that the perceptions are what probably matter the most. So if you perceive that your partner is not being very responsive to you because they're on their phone all the time, you're probably not going to be that happy in your relationship.
但当你远离自我报告时，人们完全不知道自己实际上在社交媒体上花费了多少时间。所以当你进行客观观察时，我们发现，情侣使用智能手机的频率与他们在关系中的满意度之间几乎没有什么关联（如果有的话），这让我感到惊讶。至少在手机对我们亲密关系的影响方面，真正起作用的似乎是感知。因此，如果你感知到你的伴侣对你不太有响应，因为他们一直在玩手机，你在关系中可能就不会那么快乐。
To what extent is that grounded in reality? small part of it is certainly grounded in reality, but a big part of it is grounded in how we see ourselves, in our personalities, how we kind of globally assess our relationship. If I'm in a relationship that I think is really good, I'm more likely to give my partner the benefit of the doubt when asked about, does your partner listen to you when they're on their phone? whereas if I'm really not in a great relationship, or maybe even if I'm really annoyed at my partner that day, and you ask me that same question, I'll be like, yeah, she does seem to use her phone a lot and ignore me. So this is one where I think we really need greater clarity on the links
这种感知在现实中有多大程度的依据？其中一小部分当然是有现实依据的，但很大一部分取决于我们如何看待自己、我们的个性，以及我们如何全面地评估我们的关系。如果我身处一段我认为非常好的关系中，当被问及“当你的伴侣在玩手机时，他们会听你说话吗”时，我更有可能选择相信我的伴侣；而如果我身处一段并不是很好的关系中，或者甚至如果我那天真的很生伴侣的气，而你问我同样的问题，我就会觉得：是的，她好像确实经常玩手机并忽视我。所以这是一个我认为我们确实需要更清晰地了解网络、社交媒体和总体技术之间的联系以及它如何影响我们关系的话题。
between online, say, social media and technologies in general and how it impacts our relationships. I would surmise that if there's a negative, it's mainly through taking people, away from in-person social interactions. So if people are spending so much time online that they're neglecting in-person social interactions, and it's positive, it can be positive in a number of ways. I mean, in finding social support, in forming connections with people that then become stronger connections offline, informing new friendships with people generally. It can be, you know, there are a lot of benefits. But the negatives, I think, are less clear. And I'm becoming becoming more murky than I am clearer about my thoughts on this. But again, that's kind of what
我推测，如果说有什么负面影响的话，它主要是通过让人们远离面对面的社会互动来实现的。因此，如果人们花在网上的时间太多，以至于忽略了面对面的社会互动，这就会产生负面影响；而它也可以在很多方面带来积极影响。我的意思是，在寻找社会支持、与他人形成随后在线下变得更强的连接、以及普遍与他人建立新友谊方面。它可能具有，你知道，有很多好处。但负面影响，我认为并没有那么清晰。对于这个问题的看法，我变得越来越模糊，而不是越来越清晰。但话又说回来，这也是让它令人兴奋的地方。
makes it exciting too. You know, initially we thought social media was so bad and now we think, ah, maybe it's not so bad. You know, and I tell parents this when I give talk sometimes at schools, you know, don't worry so much. So if we see a couple in a restaurant say where they're both on their phones, it doesn't necessarily mean that they have a crummy relationship, right? I mean, we don't know. No, not necessarily. Yeah, they may be both introverts. They might be both trying to figure out what they're going to be ordering at the restaurant, right? Now, if you see a couple that's spending most of the meal doing that, they probably don't have a great relationship, but it's not necessarily just because of that phone use. That phone use is probably more of a
最初我们认为社交媒体太糟糕了，现在我们觉得，啊，也许它没那么糟糕。你知道的，我有时在学校做演讲时也会这样告诉家长：不要太担心。所以，如果我们看到餐馆里的一对情侣都在玩手机，这并不一定意味着他们的关系很糟糕，对吧？我的意思是，我们并不知道。不，不一定。是的，他们可能都是内向的人。他们可能都在试图弄清楚他们要在餐馆点什么菜，对吧？现在，如果你看到一对情侣把大部分用餐时间都花在那个上面，他们的关系可能确实不太好，但这不一定仅仅是因为手机的使用。手机的使用可能更多是一种症状，而不是真正导致关系不满意的驱动因素。
symptom than it is actually driving relationship dissatisfaction. So you did another interesting study a few years ago that we might call the double date study where you looked at how interacting with another couple affected couples' feelings for each other? What was the impetus for that study and what did you find? Yeah, that was one of my favorites of our studies. I did that as part of my dissertation when I was at the University of Texas. And something that had always intrigued me that was really understudied was the effect of social networks on people's intimate relationships. My wife and I have been very fortunate to have great friends that we have as a couple and both individuals and couple friends. And this was a case maybe a little bit of what we call
所以你几年前做了另一项有趣的研究，我们可以称之为“双重约会研究”（double date study），你在其中研究了与另一对情侣互动如何影响情侣对彼此的感情？这项研究的契机是什么，你发现了什么？是的，那是我最喜欢的我们做过的研究之一。那是我在德克萨斯大学（University of Texas）攻读博士学位期间作为论文的一部分做的。一直以来让我着迷且被严重低估的一件事是社会网络对人们亲密关系的影响。我和我的妻子非常幸运，作为一对情侣以及各自作为个人，我们都有很好的情侣朋友。这可能有点符合我们所说的“自我研究”（me search），你知道，我当时想弄清楚，这是怎么回事？
me search, you know, where I wanted to figure out, you know, what is it about it? Is it that my wife and I are just happy in our relationship and therefore we are forming more friendships together, or is there something inherently beneficial about sharing friends with your spouse? And so the way that we did this was we brought couples, pairs of couples into the lab. And we basically provided them the context to have a really good first date. We did this through a pretty neat technique that was developed by the psychologist Art Aaron. called the Fast Friends, which is 45 minutes of questions that you take turns asking one another that increase in amount of self-disclosure. So, like, the first couple of questions are just fun ones,
是因为我和妻子在关系中本身就很幸福，因此我们共同结交了更多朋友，还是与配偶共享朋友本身就具有某种固有的益处？我们做这项研究的方法是，我们将情侣、成对的情侣带到实验室。我们基本上为他们提供了一个进行一次非常棒的第一次约会的语境。我们通过心理学家阿特·阿伦（Art Aron）开发的一项非常巧妙的技术做到了这一点，称为“快速朋友”（Fast Friends），这是45分钟的问题，你们轮流向对方提问，问题的自我披露程度逐渐增加。比如，前几个问题只是有趣的问题，
like if there was anybody that you could have as a dinner guest, living or dead, who would that be? What would constitute a perfect day for you? You kind of go around, and these are sort of icebreakers, But then you get into some pretty deep stuff, like, what's your relationship with your parents like? And at the end of that, what we found was compared to those in a small talk condition, which was pretty boring. The couples in the fast friends condition, they really felt close to the other couples. Fully a third of them when we followed up with them a month later became friends in real life, which is, which I think is pretty remarkable given, you know, I'm not sure a third of the couples I meet I want to become friends with.
比如：如果有任何人可以作为你的晚餐客人，无论是活着的还是死去的，那会是谁？对你来说，完美的一天是什么样的？你们轮流回答，这些都是破冰问题。但随后你们会进入一些相当深刻的内容，比如：你和父母的关系是什么样的？在这一切结束之后，我们发现，与处于无聊的小聊天条件下的对照组相比，处于“快速朋友”条件下的情侣们确实对其他情侣感到亲密。一个月后当我们对他们进行跟进随访时，足足有三分之一的人在现实生活中成为了朋友，这我认为相当了不起，因为，我不确定我遇到的情侣中有三分之一是我愿意与之成为朋友的。
And, but I think what was most interesting was after, after this double date, people felt better about their own relationships. So they felt closer to their romantic partner. And in a follow-up study that was done by my former grad student, Keith Welker, we found that couples who went through the fast friends with other couples, they also felt more passionately in love with their partner. So this kind of gets to the sexual satisfaction, you know, passion is very much tied in with that. And it's hard to maintain passion for your partner over time. And this seemed like it at least gave people a short-term boost. So the take home for this is that
但是，我认为最有趣的是，在这次双重约会之后，人们对自己的关系感觉更好了。因此，他们觉得与浪漫伴侣更亲密了。在我前研究生基思·韦尔克（Keith Welker）进行的一项后续研究中，我们发现经历了与其他情侣进行“快速朋友”的情侣，他们对伴侣的浪漫激情也更高了。所以这有点关系到性满意度，你知道，激情与此密切相关。随着时间的推移，对伴侣保持激情是很困难的。而这似乎至少给人们带来了短期的提升。所以这其中的核心启示是，
double dates can be really great for your relationship. And I think that's one of those things that we really missed during the pandemic. Speaking of the pandemic, let's talk for a minute about your love in the time of COVID project. Because it's gotten a lot of media attention, people are really interested in how relationships are faring through the pandemic. So what have you found so far? It's still ongoing, right? I mean, you haven't. It is still ongoing. In fact, we're having our biweekly meeting tomorrow. It's given me a great source of meaning during the pandemic and it's been really fun and interesting to be a part of this project.
双重约会对你的关系真的很有益。我认为那是我们在疫情期间真正怀念的事情之一。说到疫情，让我们花一点时间谈谈你的“疫情之爱”（Love in the Time of COVID）项目。因为它受到了很多媒体的关注，人们真的很关心情侣们在疫情期间的关系进展。那么到目前为止你发现了什么？这项研究仍在进行中，对吧？我的意思是，你还没有结束。它确实仍在进行中。事实上，我们明天还要召开双周例会。在疫情期间，它为我提供了一个巨大的意义来源，参与这个项目非常有趣且引人入胜。
We started it at the end of March 2020, just like a week after everything shut down. And it's been going since then, and we're now, I think, at our 13th wave of data collection. And we started with a ton of people. So the first few waves, we have a few thousand people. We're now down to a core group of about five or 600 people that have stuck with us the whole time, for which I am extremely grateful. because we've learned so much about just generally what people are doing to cope better during the pandemic. And it's shown us a lot of interesting things.
我们在2020年3月底开始了这项研究，就在一切封锁后的一周左右。从那时起它一直在进行，我想我们现在已经进行到第13波数据收集了。我们开始时有大量的人。因此在前几波中，我们有数千人。我们现在精简到了一个核心群体，大约有五六百人一直坚持到最后，对此我深表感谢。因为我们对人们在疫情期间为了更好地应对而普遍在做的事情了解了太多。它向我们展示了许多有趣的事情。
People who have been getting outside more during the pandemic are a lot happier. People who are exercising more are happier. And not surprisingly, relationships play a key role, especially face-to-face one. So for those people that were able to have pods or, you know, small groups of people that they, that they were comfortable seeing during the pandemic, those in-person interactions were associated with boosts and happiness and lower levels of depression during the pandemic. Spending time with your kids can be both a stressor during the pandemic, but also can give people a great sense of meaning. Zoom was an interesting thing that we've been looking at. That was one of those things I would never have predicted at the very beginning. of the pandemic would end up being one of these things that we studied. But we found the smaller
在疫情期间经常去户外的人要快乐得多。多锻炼的人更快乐。毫无疑问，关系起到了关键作用，特别是面对面的关系。因此，对于那些能够在疫情期间拥有社交泡沫（pods）或他们感到舒适可以见面的小群体的那些人来说，那些面对面的互动与幸福感的提升以及疫情期间较低的抑郁水平相关。花时间陪孩子在疫情期间既可能是一个压力源，但也能够给人们带来巨大的意义感。Zoom是我们一直在研究的一件有趣的事情。那是我在疫情刚开始时绝对预测不到会成为我们研究对象的事情之一。但我们发现，较小的
Zoom calls, the smaller video chats seem to be the most gratifying to people, that they feel more connected after a one-on-one because it much more approximates an in-person social interaction than does a large Zoom call. The problem with a large video chat, even though they can have their merit certainly and people have had these Zoom happy hours and things like that. But it's not a natural happy hour, right? Like at a happy hour, you're not going to be sitting around to the circle of people going, okay, you talk next, you go next, you go next, right? You're going to be pairing off maybe with one or two people over here. You know, maybe you say, okay, I'm going to go get another drink because the conversation was boring. And then, you know, you have, it's much more
Zoom通话，即较小的视频聊天，似乎对人们最有满足感，他们在进行了一对一聊天后会感到更多的连接，因为它比大型Zoom通话要更接近面对面的社会互动。大型视频聊天的问题在于，尽管它们当然有其价值，人们也举行过这类Zoom欢乐时光（happy hours）之类的活动。但它并不是一场自然的欢乐时光，对吧？就像在欢乐时光里，你不会围成一圈人，然后说：“好的，接下来你讲，下一个你讲，下一个你讲，”对吧？你可能会在这里和一两个人结成小对子。你知道，也许你会说：“好吧，我要去拿杯饮料，因为这个对话有点无聊。”然后，你知道，你会有，它要
organic, right? And it allows much more of a give and take. Whereas online, it's really, you know, there's a lot of listening, hopefully, and just a little bit of talking. And so it's, that's why we think that the small ones are much more like the conversation you and I are having. That's much more akin to a real world conversation. And one of the more interesting things from our Zoom findings was that extroverts in particular loathe large Zoom calls because they can't talk. So they don't have the opportunity like they would at a party to really to have that social need met. And also, they can't be responded to. I said before, the importance of responsiveness. And it's really hard to feel responded to in a large Zoom call
有机得多，对吧？它允许更多的给予和接受。而在网上，实际上，你知道，会有很多倾听（希望如此），只有一点点说话。所以这就是为什么我们认为小的聚会更像你和我正在进行的对话。那更类似于现实世界的对话。从我们的Zoom研究中得到的最有趣的事情之一是，外向者特别讨厌大型Zoom通话，因为他们无法说话。所以他们不像在派对上那样有机会真正满足那种社会需求。此外，他们无法得到回应。我之前说过响应性的重要性。在大型Zoom通话中，真的很难感受到被回应，
because people are distracted, you don't know if they're really paying attention to you. The cues are not there like they would be in real life. So that's kind of interesting, too. Another finding that we had was about extroversion. This reminds me, if you spend any time on Twitter, which I have from time to time, there were a lot of memes early last year about look out for your extroverted friends. They're really suffering right now. And from everything that I know as a psychologist about extroversion, I thought, I don't think that's right.
因为人们分心了，你不知道他们是否真的在关注你。线索并不像在现实生活中那样存在。所以这也是一件很有趣的事情。我们的另一个发现与外向性有关。这让我想起，如果你花任何时间在Twitter上——我有时会这样做——去年年初有很多模因（memes）都在说：照顾好你的外向者朋友。他们现在真的在受苦。而根据我作为心理学家对外向性的所有了解，我想：我觉得这不对。
I think extroverts are generally probably doing better right now. Extroverts tend to have more energy. They tend to find creative solutions to social problems in terms of like making sure those social needs get met, whereas introverts will often in a situation like the pandemic not have the inclination to sort of make the effort to stay socially connected. And they tend to be a little bit lower in energy too. so you're not going to see people going outside as much. And that's actually exactly what we found was that over the first three months of the pandemic, the most extroverted people showed the fewest depressive symptoms. They showed the highest levels of happiness and meaning in life. And we found that that was at least partially explained by feeling more socially connected
我认为外向的人目前总体上可能过得更好。外向的人往往有更多的精力。他们倾向于为社交问题寻找创造性的解决方案，比如确保这些社交需求得到满足，而内向的人在疫情这样的情况下，往往没有倾斜度去努力保持社交联系。而且他们的精力也往往稍低一些，所以你不会看到人们经常去户外。而这实际上正是我们所发现的，在疫情的前三个月里，最外向的人表现出的抑郁症状最少。他们表现出最高水平的幸福感和生活意义。我们发现，这至少部分可以通过感到更多的社交联系来解释
with other people compared to their more introverted counterparts. And also doing things like exercising more, getting outside more, All those things that we already know during the pandemic were good for people's well-being. So, yeah, lots of interesting findings. We have a big, it's a big international consortium at this point of a bunch of researchers working on this project. And so we seem to have new findings every week. One of the things we were about to look at is long-distance relationships during the pandemic, which we know very little about how distance may have impacted people.
与更内向的人相比，他们与其他人的交往更多。也做一些事情，比如多锻炼，多去户外，所有这些我们在疫情期间就已经知道的事情都有益于人们的福祉。所以，是的，有很多有趣的发现。在这一点上，我们有一个大型的国际联合研究小组，由许多研究人员组成，他们都在进行这个项目。因此，我们似乎每周都有新的发现。我们要研究的事情之一是疫情期间的远程恋爱，对于距离如何影响人们，我们所知甚少。
Well, another area where you've done some researchers looking at cross-cultural relationships, I know you worked with couples in Japan. What similarities or differences did you find in terms of how close relationships affect health and well-being in different cultures? So the project that I told you about where we followed, where we had data for couples over 20 years, this midlife in the United States study in Wisconsin, it turns out that there is a corollary study to it in Japan that has all of the exact same measures. age-matched with the Wisconsin sample. So it offers a really nice opportunity for researchers to look at differences between two pretty different cultures. On the one hand, the United States, which is what we would call a more independent culture, a more individualistic culture, and then Japan on the
嗯，你在其中做过一些研究的另一个领域是跨文化关系，我知道你曾与日本的伴侣合作过。在亲密关系如何影响不同文化的健康和福祉方面，你发现了哪些相似之处或不同之处？所以我跟你讲过的那个项目，我们追踪了伴侣长达20年的数据，即威斯康星州的中年美国人研究，结果发现日本有一个与它相对应的研究，其中包含了完全相同的测量指标。与威斯康星州的样本年龄相匹配。因此，它为研究人员提供了一个非常好的机会，来观察两个截然不同的文化之间的差异。一方面是美国，我们可以称之为更独立的文化，一种更具个人主义的文化，而日本在
other, which is a more collectivistic or interdependent culture. And so this emerged out of a graduate course on social relationships that I teach, where we were talking about responsiveness And one of the PhD students in the class said, you know, Rich, you keep talking about how important responsiveness is in people's intimate relationships. But I lived in Japan for a few years. And the outside relationships, outside the intimate relationships. So relationships with family members especially seem to be a lot more important. And she said, I just think that responsiveness is going to matter less for people's happiness there than it would here.
另一方面，这是一个更具集体主义或相互依赖的文化。这源于我教授的一门关于社会关系的毕业生课程，我们在课上讨论了反应性。班上的一名博士生说，你知道，里奇，你一直在谈论反应性在人们的亲密关系中有多么重要。但我曾在日本生活过几年。外在的关系，在亲密关系之外的关系。因此，与家庭成员的关系似乎要重要得多。她说，我只是认为，在那里，反应性对人们幸福感的重要性将不如在这里重要。
And so she did some preliminary analyses and I bumped into a very close colleague at a meeting who I've published a few papers on responsiveness with. And I told him about this idea and he said, you're not going to believe it. We're looking at that exact same question. And so we joined forces to look at this. And what we found was, as my student initially had thought, there were differences. Now, responsiveness in your relationship still was associated. with greater well-being in Japan, but not to the same extent as it is here in the United States. Here, how responsive your intimate partner is seems to matter a lot more because we put so much weight
于是她做了一些初步的分析，我在一次会议上遇到了一个非常亲密的同事，我曾和他一起发表过几篇关于反应性的论文。我把这个想法告诉了他，他说，你不会相信的。我们正在研究完全相同的问题。于是我们联手来研究这个问题。我们发现，正如我的学生最初所想的那样，确实存在差异。现在，你的关系中的反应性仍然与日本更高的幸福感相关，但没有像在美国这样达到相同的程度。在这里，你的亲密伴侣的反应有多快似乎更重要，因为我们寄予了太多的厚望
on our intimate relationships. Eli Finkel has done some really nice work in this area, the social psychologist at Northwestern University, who's written a book called The All or Nothing marriage. And he has hypothesized that in Western society, over the last 100 years or so, the intimate relationship has been almost an exclusive focus for us in terms of, for those that are in intimate relationships for pathways to happiness and meaning in life. In other words, we are expecting more and more from our intimate partners in terms of helping us to be happy. And for those marriages that are incredibly happy and bring us meaning, people seem to be highly self-actualized and to use terms of Abraham Maslow. Whereas those couples where they're not getting those needs, self-esteem needs and those kinds of needs, you know, about that deal with the core self, those kinds of needs met, that they're miserable at the extremes.
在我们亲密的关系上。伊利·芬克尔（Eli Finkel）在这个领域做了一些非常出色的工作，他是西北大学的社会心理学家，曾写过一本名为《全部或无的婚姻》的书。他假设，在西方社会，在过去的100年左右里，亲密关系几乎成了我们唯一的焦点，对于那些处于亲密关系中的人来说，它是通往幸福和生活意义的途径。换句话说，我们对亲密伴侣的期望越来越高，希望他们能帮助我们获得幸福。对于那些极其幸福并带给我们意义的婚姻来说，人们似乎是高度自我实现的，并使用了亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的术语。而对于那些没有满足这些需求的伴侣来说，自尊需求和那种需求，你知道的，涉及核心自我的需求，没有得到满足，他们在极端情况下会痛苦不堪。
And our data seem to suggest that, yes, that is more true here than in countries like Japan, where there's not as much pressure on intimate partners to satisfy all of your needs. The family, the extended social network is more important there than it is here. And I think there's a lesson to be learned there, you know, that maybe we're putting too much pressure on our relationships to make us happy. So, keying off of that, we've been talking a lot about research and theory. So let me ask a question for listeners who might be interested in more practical advice and wisdom that they can draw from your research. Last question, what are the most important things people can do to improve their relationships and become better partners?
我们的数据似乎表明，是的，这在这里比在日本等国更真实，因为在日本，亲密伴侣满足你所有需求的压力没有那么大。家庭、扩展的社会网络在那里比在这里更重要。我认为这里有一个经验教训，你知道，也许我们在关系上施加了太多的压力来让我们快乐。因此，延续这一点，我们一直在讨论很多关于研究和理论的内容。所以让我为那些可能对更多实用建议和智慧感兴趣的听众问一个问题，这些建议和智慧可以从你的研究中汲取。最后一个问题，人们为了改善关系和成为更好的伴侣，可以做的最重要的事情是什么？
Excellent question to end up. Try to be as responsive a partner as you can. And that starts with being a good listener to your partner. When you come home from work, put the phone down, when your partner makes a bid for your attention, really try to, try to pay attention to them and then more broadly to try to be sensitive to their needs. But I think being a really good listener is a key part of that. One of the things that we know is a good booster for relationships is what we call novel and exciting activities.
这是一个很好的结束问题。试着成为一个尽可能有反应的伴侣。这要从做一个倾听伴侣的好听众开始。当你下班回家时，放下手机，当你的伴侣试图引起你的注意时，真的试着，试着关注他们，然后更广泛地试着对他们的需求敏感。但我认为成为一个真正好的听众是其中的关键部分。我们所知道的对关系的一个很好的促进因素是我们所谓的“新奇和令人兴奋的活动”。
Try something new together. And there's lots of things that will seem new now that we're coming out of the pandemic that we haven't done for a long time. But go on a hike together. Go on a double date together. or just go on a date to a restaurant you haven't tried. You know, trying new things that are fun can be a boost to people's relationships. For parents out there, and I have some friends that are new parents,
一起尝试新事物。现在随着我们走出疫情，许多事情都会显得很新，这是我们很长一段时间没有做过的。但是一起去远足吧。一起去约会吧。或者只是去一家你没去过的餐厅约会。你知道，尝试有趣的新事物可以促进人们的关系。对于为人父母的人来说，我有一些刚为人父母的朋友，
it's really important to maintain that connection and to try to do things with your spouse to try to keep that connection going because the strength of those two parent families comes from the strength of their relationship. and the importance of social networks. You know, if you're finding that you and your partner don't do a lot with friends together, I would suggest that they look at that and see if there are ways that they can branch out a bit, maybe have some work colleagues and their spouses over to your place or neighbors because they can be so enriching for our relationships.
保持这种联系非常重要，并尝试和你的配偶一起做事情，以保持这种联系的持续，因为这两个父母家庭的力量来自于他们关系的强度。以及社会网络的重要性。你知道，如果你发现你和你的伴侣不经常和朋友一起做事情，我建议他们看看这一点，看看是否有办法稍微扩展一下，也许可以请一些同事和他们的配偶到你家里来或者邻居，因为他们对我们的关系非常有益。
Well, thank you, Dr. Slatcher. This has been really interesting. I appreciate all of your insights. and hearing about your research, which is just fascinating. Thank you. Well, it's been fun for me. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please, if you like us, leave a review.
好的，谢谢你，斯莱彻博士。这真的很有趣。我很感激你所有的见解，并听到你的研究，这简直太迷人了。谢谢你。嗯，对我来说也很有趣。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站www.combeckycology.org上找到《心理学对话》以前的剧集，或者在苹果、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到它们。请如果你喜欢我们，请留下一条评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学对话》由莉·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔丁。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。